-Our first guest tonight
is the co-chair
of the Bill & Melinda Gate
Foundation
and author of the new book "Ho
to Avoid a Climate Disaster:
The Solutions We Have
and the Breakthroughs We Need,
which is on sale now.
Please welcome to the show
Bill Gates.
How are you, Bill?
-I'm great.
-Thanks so much
for making time for us.
I want to talk about the book.
Obviously, people know you
as a philanthropist.
They know you as the co-chai
of the Bill & Melinda Gate
Foundation.
You also have a podcast with
my dear friend Rashida Jones
Maybe not
the most obvious pairing.
How did that start?
-A friend from Hollywood sai
that we were complementary
and, in fact, it ended up
being a lot of fun.
You know, she's got
a creative background.
I do not.
I'm kind of science-oriented
and so we picked five topics
and went well.
-Yes, I can tell you,
you might not have
an entertainment background,
but as a friend,
she's been useless
with my computer problems,
so I'm glad the two of you
found each other.
You know, I want to talk
a little bit about vaccine
before we move on to climate
And obviously, it was
a bit of a bumpy start
with the rollout
here in the States.
Things are obviously
looking a lot better.
But you were focusing
on the importance
to get vaccines
into developing countries.
Why do you think it's importan
for people to step back
and not just look at this as a
national issue but a global one?
-Well, the first reason is
that we don't want other human
to die.
And so helping them out
is morally important,
but also we want the world
economy to go back to normal
It creates jobs here.
And we'd also like to avoi
the disease constantly returning
to our country.
If we can actually get it
to super-low numbers
everywhere in the world
or even to zero,
then tourism, travel,
all these things can resume,
which is very, very important.
And so we're kind of
all in it together
because, you know,
people travel a lot,
and we can share these vaccine
not just based on
who has the most money.
-You talk about how
we're all in this together
and you're someone who,
over the course of your career
has tried very hard to wor
with people across the aisle
I think you've looked at it as
you know,
we have to put aside
our differences
when we're talking about thing
that are for the greater good.
Yet it also seems like science
specifically,
has been politicized more
maybe in this year
than at any point
in my lifetime.
Do you find that depressin
when you try to move forward
with this?
-Well, it's sad that
the U.S. response was so poor.
People had expected it to be one
of the best in the world.
And in one respect it was good
We funded a lot
of this vaccine work.
Of these first five vaccines
four of them,
there were big amounts of mone
from the BARDA department
of the government.
And that's now showing us
that this will come to an end.
These vaccines are miracles.
Thank God that the private
sector, with government money,
has pulled these together.
But in other respects the last
year has been frustrating
because the willingness
to push guidelines
and admit that things are tough,
you know, the ability
to show leadership on masks,
and now encouraging
vaccine uptake.
You know, I think the U.S.
has a lot to look back on
and, you know, figure out
that when this comes next time
we have to do better.
-You know, obviously in the last
week we've seen states --
Texas, Mississippi
as a couple of examples --
they are now, you know,
from the governor's office dow
rescinding the statewide
masks orders.
Is that something
that you find distressing,
especially after everything yo
would have hoped we've learned
in the last year?
-Yeah, I just don't think
wearing a mask
is such a deep inconvenience
I mean, we ask people
to wear pants.
You know, why was this
politicized?
The mask helps a lot.
And although we're near the end,
every death is tragic.
-Now I feel terrible
about the fact that I --
I should admit
I'm not wearing pants now.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, don't go outside.
You might infect somebody.
-[ Laughs ]